[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur bonal tv spéciale
leçon pour débutants avec ninon
maisuradze et bonjour ça va nino oui
alors qu'est ce qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on voir une des possibilités
de nulle part pat pâte et après on va
passer sur le même thème avec une piste
suicidaire comme un faire part
voilà donc en fait on va voir il ya les
combinaisons de maths donc ça c'est pour
gagner
il a on va voir des combinaisons en fait
de pâtes moche alors ça c'est
extraordinaire liste oui c'est très joli
et il faut dire ça c'est plutôt rare par
rapport les autres possibilités de nuls
dans la pratique mais ça avait quand
même à ce moment moi même je fais
plaisir pour ma part j'ai sauvé la
partie alors on va voir sa déposition de
pattes alors le pâtre aux échecs fide on
nous rappelle rapidement si simplement
que vous n'êtes pas un échec mais vous
avez aucun coup dans ce cas là c'est nul
parce que ben vous pouvez pas jouer
alors que mais vous n'êtes pas un échec
la différence avec le match c'est que
non seulement vous pouvez pas jouer n'y
a pas de coups mais vous êtes en plus un
échec donc là ses échecs et mat alors le
pas de ces parties nulles exemple de pas
tout de suite ici
regardez la tam pc-7 ici contrôle à
cause des huit contrôles la casse
bessette et las casas est le roi lui
n'est pas en échec il ya aucune pièce
qui fait échec suppose que c'est très
haut noir essayé ils n'ont pas de coût
et c'est ça nous voilà si c'était très
haut blanc mais faudrait sans doute
bouger la dame
par exemple pour donner un peu déroutant
ensuite on ramènerait le rang et offrit
maths mais la sicile venant de jouer
c'est pat et pat ces parties nulles
alors quand on a compris ça et bien on
va voir qu'on peut parfois forcé le pat
on y souvent plutôt forcer le match mais
là on va forcer le pat et vous allez
voir que ça peut être très très jolie
effectivement donc on revient au numéro
de notre exemple de pacte juste pour
savoir que c'est pas forcément avec la
dern
il peut avoir l'impression ou encore
plus simple simplifier ici l'ours et les
blancs t-il sans doute ont forcé le pat
il met le roi ici sur laquelle ils ont
deux sans doute pu jouer ce coup là par
exemple est bien le roi ne peut plus
bouger et donc il pourra pas à faire
promotion vice champion et c'est nul il
faut y a pas de coups parce qu'elle est
noire cd richard marks and well et noir
se dirige vers le bas évidemment
donc c'est là c'est parti voilà donc
c'est un autre exemple ici de deux
pattes alors position suivante donc bien
comprendre cette notion de pâtes
alors ça c'est pas ça c'est encore une
pulsion de pâte plus original un peu
plus original un peu plus il ya un peu
plus de pièces à une poly j'ai d'avoir
peu de pièces pour qui n'est pas trop
regarder les noirs le roi n'est pas en
échec ni la dame nature ne font écho au
moins puisque le cavalier ici intercepte
position alors on peut pas bouger le
cavalier avec les noirs puisque les
couleurs puisqu'il est loué
hayward et les deux pions soit
immobilisé si si on en deux journées
cette position c'est nul y'a pas tu donc
c'est un pas de parc louage ses écrits
ici pas de partout voilà on va voir une
autre position ici voilà alors là par
contre il n'y a pas pas tout de suite
ces eaux noires de jouer il n'y a pas de
pattes alors pourquoi parce
qu'évidemment le roi dans le rhône on ne
peut pas jouer
regardez le pion c7 en fait je devenir
des 8 contre on est casés vos rois
contrôler cet essai test avant la tour
contrôler toute la rangée ainsi que le
roi tout est contrôlé mais nenê mais il
reste un pion
oui donc c'est au noir de jouer de façon
on n'a pas le choix il faut pousser les
pions parce qu'il n'est pas de quoi donc
il n'ya pas parce qu'on peut jouer une
pièce 1 voilà oui c'est ça mais
attention par exemple aussi si par
hasard vous faites promotion d'un
cavalier par exemple dans ces cas vous
permet alors imaginons qu'on fasse
promotion cavaliers ce qu'on a le droit
ce sera bizarre mais bon si l'on fait
ici et bien les blancs peuvent tout
simplement jouer des tours à huit échec
au roi et juin c'est matt seimat
donc quand les photos présentent donc
ici on a tout simplement joué ouais
c'est on peut faire confiance qu'on veut
mais souvent il faut faire s'il faut
alors qu'est ce que vous avez déjà
dominé qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et
c'est d'ailleurs parce que c'est pas si
compliqué que ça
oui bon on le fait tout simplement
d'avoir la dent pourquoi d'âme parce
qu'elle s'adonne échec en même temps ou
plus si l'échec c'est une forme de
fourchettes en fait qui oblige les bleus
à reprendre la dame parce que lorenzo
trois moyens sinon ils vont perdre
si on joue le roi évidemment ici on joue
le roi pour par un échec
dimpre entoure aussi les noirs qui gagne
donc on prend la dame mais regardez le
roi noir ne peut pas bouger donc ses
pattes et maintenance et ses pattes
voilà donc la séparant une combinaison
c'est pas tellement le choix ne s'est
pas ici on encore mais voilà donc tout
de suite il n'y a pas patte mais le fait
qu'on puisse faire dame fait que voilà
on force le path donc ouais c'est pas
très compliqué d'ailleurs il faut juste
savoir 7
cette idée déjà et après bien regarder
sur le chéquier position suivante et si
la tron alors un peu plus subtil
regardez ici donc les blancs sont dans
une position de quasi pâte puisque le
roi ne peut pas bouger ils ont plus qu
une pièce qui est le pion alors faut pas
se tromper est pas sorcier blanc par
jour le coût qui serait une faute
apprends b5 les noirs ne reprendraient
pas le pion parce que les blancs en
repas de cas de coups simplement il joue
un coup comme dame par exemple ou tout
simplement
et si les blancs reprenne un pion là on
peut reprendre puisque là le roi a de
l'espace et après bien sûr avec une
dette de plus et c'est qu'on va gagner
la partie facile
voilà donc il faudrait que les blancs
trouve autre chose alors ils trouvent un
coup l'autre poule plus qui marche c'est
le coup à cinq échecs
un très joli parce qu'il ya les toutes
les pauses il ya plusieurs coups pour
les pour les noirs soit il bouge le roi
en bessette
mais c'est quand même pas tu puisque le
roi peut pas bouger et le pion est
bloquée qui couve avec un chèque et il
est l'arrivée sur la case où il est
bloqué voilà soit on prend lyon et c'est
pareil on ne peut plus bouffi loin dans
les deux cas donc si le boulot beaucoup
ici c'est pas de prendre mes 5 c'est
bien de jouer à 5 go fait attention
la prise est pas toujours le meilleur
cousy chèque il ya souvent les
subtilités à ne pas prendre donc très
très souvent que du très souvent c'est à
chaque fois posez vous la question à
chaque coup mais ce qu'ils voulaient
prendre ne pas prendre mais là en
l'occurrence il vaut mieux pas prendre
et jouer le coup à cinq et on force
pattes d'une petite astuce peut-être
pour donner pour d'évidents surtout dans
les parties glitz quand on voulait
partir rapide
souvent si vous perdez et vous continuez
à vous est désespérée parfois on va
pousser spécialement les pions sur les
cases ou ne sont bloqués et soi même
sacrifié on avait fait ça en fait
parfois je sors le parti gironde cinq
minutes c'est dans l'église
en fait l'amour est vrai marqué s'il ya
le plus de pions par exemple sur le
béton on ne pourrait jamais faire patte
parce qu on aura le coût supplémentaire
et ce sera pas parce qu'on aura donc aux
possibilités vous pouvez les pistes
c'est pour ça parfois j'essaie creevy
spécialement du ps afin de
si j'ai plus rien après il ya plus de
chance faire patte en fait c'est un beau
mâle homme vous c'est pas très noble
peut-être mais vous pouvez ça va partir
comme ça vous pouvez penser à ça - de
pesos aurait de toute façon si vous êtes
perdant désespéré plus de chance faire
pas voilà donc le pat ressources souvent
inattendue alors ici très original alors
là par contre dans le thème qui est très
connue alors moi j'ai vu une partie même
du grand maître olivier ronnie au grand
prix de bordeaux 2007 qui est sûr des
gones al tv n'avions vous pouvez
regarder cette émission face à mathieu
cornette quarts de finale du grand prix
qu'ils aient entièrement filmé et vous
allez voir un extraordinaire tour folle
ce qu'on va voir aussi la tour folle de
mathieu cornette vous
voyez cette cette partie extraordinaire
grand prix de bordeaux 2007 quart de
finale et même en grand maître donc peut
faire se faire planter entre guillemets
une tour folle alors qu'il était archi
gagnant est bien le candidat m parce
qu'il était candidat à ce moment là
mathieu cornette a réussi à sauver la
partie grâce à ça alors regardez c'est
exactement ce qu'on va voir là tout de
suite on a une position de quasi pâte
qu'on l'a vu tout à l'heure puisque la
dame contrôler toutes les cases durable
en est par contre les blancs encore une
tour et le problème c'est que les noirs
en plus menace tout de suite
nas damage de man et atteint 9,3 être
les premières menaces et ya pas de coup
si on joue la tournée pour tous ses
matches voilà alors même que le problème
ce pour les noirs c'est qu'il ya ce
qu'on appelle une tour folle et alors
qu'est ce que c'est que cette pour folle
et bien c'est tout rejet trois échecs
simplement tour qui s'affolent c'est une
taupe qui s'offrent alors qu'est ce que
font les noirs orient si on prend du roi
ben c'est pas puisqu'on vient de le voir
la dame contrôler toutes les cases et si
on prend de la dame et c'est pareil
la dame en g3 n'a pas de casque contrôle
tout les cas on se dit bon c'est pas
grave hein
on va simplement me s'éloigner avec 3 et
puis c'est réglé
on essaiera trouver une solution plus
tard 3 4 mais non mais le problème pour
les événements c'est que les blancs
continuent échec
et là on commence à comprendre avec les
noirs que c'est fini on s'en sortira par
le roi de l'essor poulain continuer on
va voir qu'est-ce qu'on peut toujours
pas prendre la tour à cause du pat la
menace de pâte est là et si on revient
h3 on reviendra en g3 et si on s'éloigne
eh bien ça ne résout rien on continue à
faire échec donc c'est un échec
perpétuelle on va finir par répéter
trois fois la position
on peut même demander la nullité tout de
suite puisque le roi blanc noir ne peut
pas s'échapper et si on revient mais il
faut continuer tout simplement faire les
échecs et de loin et dès que les noirs
prennent baffe ses pattes
oui donc là a remarqué vous avez intérêt
de suivre le clac or sur le côlon j'ai
pour pas laisser le roi sortir voilà il
faut rester ici probablement s'affaire
aussi nul si on fait de tout par moments
sur h mais quand ça leur os échappe
c'est plus compliqué à prononcer locaux
compliqué pas si vous trouvez des
simples et si vous fêtez chez caché
qu'il voulait me prendre
on peut jamais prendre des qui prend ses
pattes pendant que ça ça s'appelle le
concept de la tour folle part je vous
réponds je vous invite à voir un match
réel donc un grand maître olivier rhône
et face à mathieu cornette au grand prix
de bordeaux 2007 qui est sûre diagonale
tv vous aurez le quart de finale
disponible sur le catalogue est bien
regarder ce match fantastique et qu'on
regarde et comment olivier rosay sauve
le match et même fini par gagner c'est
l'extraordinaire est donc ici aussi je
veux juste ajouter à mon parent porte
arrière quand je parlais de cette
parfois même donné les matériels ainsi
qu ici imaginez s'élève un point de plus
par exemple quelque part sur ado oui on
ne pourrait jamais faire cette
patrouille coiffeuse la tour y prend et
ça c'est pour ça dans une telle position
c'était ma partie du rsa y est que le
cndp yonne exprès bien sûr ils prennent
après je sais que j'ai répété de petite
chance de faire un pack ouais voilà
parfois il vaut mieux donner et de
faisans disposition ça va changer pas
grand chose si j'ai un peu plus au passé
perdons donc voilà je pensais à ça aussi
alors c'est vrai les parties on voit la
suite ici montréjeau une position très
jolie position les blancs ont une
position écrasante la menace des blancs
c'est évidemment tout huit matchs en
plus on voit qu'il ya des pions qui
peuvent les faire dame impasse et sont
donc en grande difficulté il y aurait
pas le pion au f5 on pourrait encore
envisager faire les échecs mais ya peint
donc les noir sans grande difficulté
mais il a aussi on va avoir une belle
combinaison de pâte qui démarre comme on
l'a vu tout à l'heure par une promotion
donc essayé trop vous même si vous
regardez sur internet vous pouvez
arrêter le cours et prendre quelques
minutes pour réfléchir sinon nous
montrait bien sûr alors forcément c'est
ont fait dame échec donc la bombe et du
coup effectivement l'idée ses cordes et
enfin avant de faire d'un échec
on constate que le roi noir et pris le
pass ya pas de gaz tout est contrôlé
donc c'est une position de casemate
on imagine si on n'avait pas de papiers
c'est une paroisse ça pourrait être pas
dans leur intérêt de tous ces crimes
donc quand vous êtes une position de
quasi pas t'as vu le roi comme ça et que
vous êtes en grande difficulté en finale
comme ça réfléchissez comme on vient de
le dire à brûler vos vaisseaux voudra
donner de vraies pièces et donc regarder
la dame donc tout reprend et là regardez
le pape se fait différemment c'est une
tour folle mais pas contre le roi ou et
contre la tour et harcèle la tour
d'abord celle en mars elle donc on donne
la tour regardez on la tourne si c'est
génial et on va la donne est certain que
la tour si elle veut éviter de alors si
on prend évidemment avec les blancs et
bien ses pattes
oui c'est pas donc si on veut garder la
tour et les avantages qu'on a il fait
bouger la tour sur la sur la rangée par
exemple tour bel et bien on continue à
poursuivre cette tour là pour folle
tombé de n'importe où y parle c'est le
même idée on empêche la tour de sortir
et devait venir faire un échec ici et si
tu prends et bien c'est pas donc il n'y
a pas d'autre dès qu'on bouge pouf
voilà on se met devant c'est pas énorme
pour partout donc
si le blanc nez ça y est par hasard
c'est crif et sa tour ça marche pas si
les seuils faire une promotion d'un
gâchis 6 par exemple si ici les blancs
se disent bon mais ces parages de l'esca
tôt mais je vais essayer de faire dame
avec un pion ils vont faire de même même
pas réussi à faire on réussit pas parce
qu'après h7 la tour voit rattrapé la
tour vient en h1 essai des blacks ont
des problèmes ils vont perdre en fait 30
ça c'est perdre maintenant parce qu'un
mot parce que si les blancs jouent
simplement ceux qui ont joué un coup
d'attendre oui ainsi sur m6 ont encore
un talent sûr m6 on joue encore un coût
d'attenté là maintenant il faut bouger
droits et devoirs des affaires dames et
tous ici on bouge il suffit de prendre
et on va ramasser tous les pions et on
va gagner avec troyes et tours donc les
blancs n'ont pas d'autre solution et
d'accepter le pat donc très belle
combinaison de patin moura je vous
rappelle un beau mélange d'abord
intéressant quand tu as dit à retenir
possibilité a recélé est une pièce pas
forcément le roi hùng à cet adversaire
bon sacré suicidé comme on dit sur sept
c'est une tour suicide et une tour foule
toujours plus tôt donc oui si on pour le
tour c'est plutôt le bcm est d'être sur
notre pays
par contre 6,06 à celui ci des pièces
folk et soul alors autres cas de alors
là c'est une dame folle dame suicidaire
c'est qu'on a eu c'est l'équivalent donc
là c'est un peu la même idée regardez le
alors le pied noir est bloqué pour les
noirs le roi est bien dans une position
de pâtes on est dans une position
désespérée puisque les blancs ont deux
gros plus on avance donc
c'est très délicat si c'était un blanc
de jouer il suffirait d essayer
d'échanger les dames pour gagner la
partie tout simplement donc aimer les
bleu et noir s'ils ont une ressource par
l'adam suicidaire la dame fall regardez
tout simplement le coup très surprenant
dame j'ai quatre échecs on donne à
darwin
si le roi blanc prend c'est pas tout de
suite
et bien c'est patent dès lors on ne peut
pas bouger et on obtient donc si on
essaie d'éviter alors général et blanc
essayé de se défendre et c'est pas
toujours possible de faire un ça
éternellement
par exemple un coup comme roi ici m6 et
même tout simplement ont fait d'armes
six échecs le roi s'y prend si l'on
reprend la dame mais c'est toujours pas
et donc si on revient bien il suffit de
faire un et chérie si donc après les
autres possibles de pour le blanc
peut-être ça y est faire un croate 6 3
il l'a cette position s'est combinée
avec une autre idée d échec perpétuerait
d'ailleurs regardez comment on fait
damages quatre échecs d'un match 4
échecs donc la maintenance et le coup
cette démarche sa gamme a5 est là pour
faire on revient à des doses et des
combinés pour deux types de nuit ces
deux types de nu une menace par le papa
d une menace par et chic perpétuelle
donc si on va si on va sur la case m6 on
revient de donner la dame
et si on va sur la cale s'ils sont faits
décrits par factuel d'armes ici dames la
tchèque on est obligé de revenir vers la
dame s'est perpétuée h 4 très bel
exemple oui comment sauver le parti
alors qu il y avait vraiment une
position perdante avec toupie ont des
mots
dans la finale c'est très difficile a
sauvé alors qu'on en a d'autres exemples
non je trouve ça fait non il celle ci
celle ci s'est très bien d'ailleurs
encore suit l'or c'est très original
la danse est possible par contre il est
important que vous sachiez que si vous
arrivez tout sacrifier les noirs ne peut
pas gagner même pas ton en fait à
remarquer et le fou noir c'est les fous
des cases noire alors qu'est la casse de
promotion de ses pions et blanche
voilà donc ça on a un pied haut à choux
un point avec le fou qui pas de la
couleur d'un cas de promotion donc si on
arrive à échanger les tours c'est nul
c'est mieux voilà et d'ailleurs c'est ce
que font les blancs tout de suite
il propose tout simplement le coutour g7
donato alors pourquoi mais on pourrait
se dire quand même ça peut être
dangereux et en fait on ne voit qu'eux
en fait après tout reprend g7
et bien justement ces pâtes oui regardez
on ne peut pas bouger et la casaque de
les protéger par le fou c'est ça qu'il
fallait voir et donc le roi peut pas
bouger donc un jeu ont regardé dans ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va donc
harceler la tourache juste une petite
remarque d'ailleurs quelqu'un peut
penser que pourquoi pas de touristes
aussi faire échec au resto et s'il prend
ses pattes mais nous y est pas obligé à
prendre si ça le problème
regardez si on voit là aussi on fait
voilà donc il faut pas se tromper parce
qu'un tour f2 pour le dire origines tour
folle oui le problème c'est qu'il peut
aussi partir on vient par exemple en
trois et on pourra plus faire la tour
fut alors après après c'est fini parce
que maintenant soit 0,2 on peut prendre
et là le roi à une casse de sortie c'est
ça donc ça serait une erreur donc il
faut pas se tromper
c'est une combinaison quand même
technique alors on va voir aussi que
c'est pas si simple
parce que il ya des combines alors donc
j'ai cette tour taxis s'il part on
harcèle et quand on harcèle encore la
tour et là on pourrait envisager de
jouer le coup fourré l4g 2 et cet
exemple soit s'il partait n'important on
harcèle et donc la seule possibilité de
peut-être faire quelque chose c'est
celle ci oui on fait ça pour éviter
parce que sinon si on bouge on harcèle
toujours la tour et là on dit fourcade
n'y a pas de problème puisque après tout
reprendre tout ce que font les blancs
fou prend voilà le roi peut se peut bien
bougé mais mais mais mais ça c'est nul
théorique en fait c'est nul parce que
l'option ça qu'on parle et voilà le pion
à pour casse de promotion de cases
blanches et le foot quatre mois
on peut pas gagner on peut pas pousser
les plus rentables et si il se fit et
vous restez sur les cases arranger un
tout simplement voilà si vous faites ça
c'est pas un problème qu'il prend votre
qu'un sevrage 3 vous lâche espion sarko
n'aime ça change rien ça changerait donc
là vous il ya pas de problèmes ne sont
pas fonction parce qu'il pourra pas vous
enlevez de la case achat
il faudrait qu'il est le fou de cases
blanches voilà pour vous enlever de
cette case donc de cette manière un
grand fois avec la torre folle en somme
la partie voilà ce alors qu'elle avait
une pièce noire une pièce folle est
toujours une combinaison de pâtes
en fait vous donner la pièce parce que
vous n'avez pas peur de la peur puisque
vous pouvez pas bougé après vous n'êtes
pas donc c'est forcément une pole c'est
un larsen pour refaire pas voilà donc là
on revient la position de départ donc de
pad classique
vous avez beaucoup de cas avec des dames
comme ça aimez vous pourrez trouver des
positions plus générale c'est très à
l'aise très intéressant c'est des façons
de sauver les parties souvent mais pas
uniquement blitz ou dans les parties
rapides on n'a pas le temps d'être dans
les positions même dans des parties
n'est jamais resté pendant les parties
lentes à faire alors dans les parties
lentes
moi ça va arriver contre - contre moi je
trouve quelqu'un de voila moi c'était
puis je me suis fait rager
j'ai sauvé quelques parties
intéressantes très important même pour
équipe je me rappelle même la dernière
c'est grâce à ça qu'on est resté à
nationale en quelque chose comme ça une
percée très important où j'avais deux
points de moi mais j'ai fait pas
d'ailleurs c'était d'envol et s'écrient
les dents c'est des 2000 points qui
valent cher chaque demi point voient
cheikh où il faut cher vaut très cher
aux échecs voilà donc cette cette leçon
sur le pat avec ces histoires de pièces
folle très important un concept vraiment
fondamental à connaître en plus de ça
fait partie du jeu et c'est des façons
de sauver quelques parties d'échecs
parfois très importantes
voilà merci à ninon terrienne la
prochaine et au revoir bientôt sur dalle
tv au revoir
[Musique]